interesting claim made on The View
yesterday about uh I don't know this is
a claim about a policy that apparently
Republicans have been supporting
this is news to me but I don't know
listen
but I will say this just like the Latina
saved the Senate young voters saved this
country and we need to really understand
that we are supposed to leave this world
in a better place than we found it when
you look at the youth voter turnout in
the 2022 midterms they delivered key
wins for the Democrats younger voters
aged 18 to 29 which by the way now the
Republicans want to raise the voting to
age 28. younger voters were the only
voter Group by age to overwhelmingly
support Democrats in the midterms 63
percent of Voters voted for Democrat
Democratic house candidates I think my
friend you know Cornell belker and you
know Cornell as well he says there are
really two electorates one older and one
younger fighting to take this country in
very different directions the Republican
party has to get with it they are dying
out and they are being we're going to
talk more about that you're up on time
here
hmm so what was that again rate she says
by the way you know Republicans I want
to raise the voting age to 28. what what
Republican has said that tell me what
we're probably going to said that
because I would I would be supporting
them I'd be campaigning for them uh no
no Republican is saying that raise the
voting age to 20. I haven't heard that
from anyone now
you know you're also mistaken like I'm
not pushing for raising the voting age
28 either I want to raise it to like 35.
um but I am far in a way in the minority
on that and I'm also not an elected
Republican
politicians and I have not heard any
suggest that we do that
um
and as we talked about yesterday
as much as I think that we should we
should raise the voting age
we should have all kinds of parameters
put in place there should be all kinds
of restrictions on voting that go Way
Beyond voter ID same-day voting I mean
that should just be the beginning of it
there should be so much more but but
none of that is going to happen
it should but it's not going to happen
and so we have to get to a point myself
certainly included in dealing with
what actually is happening
yeah our our entire system of voting is
a joke and it only becomes more of a
joke every single day
but
if we want to have any chance of
changing any of that we have to deal
with that confront that
and as I said yesterday you know figure
out how to navigate the system and
exploit the systems that are in place
Republicans in some states have figured
out how to do that you know how do you
mobilize the the mass mail-in voting
early voting none of that should exist
it shouldn't exist but it does
and so are we going to allow Democrats
to be the only ones who utilize that
or are Republicans going to start
utilizing it too systems shouldn't be
there but it is
and so take advantage of it to the
extent that you can
because the only other app what's the
other option I don't see any other
option
the other option is to on principle say
no not we're not going to do that
and then you just never win another
election ever again
foreign
policies that you oppose all of that
only gets worse as a consequence
well I hope you enjoyed that clip from
Matt Walsh show if you did be sure to
subscribe to this YouTube channel and
click the notification button to get
more content like this if you want to
watch or listen to the full show head to
dailywire.com And subscribe today you
can also listen to my podcast on Spotify
Apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcasts